because then would you say that
um
dating app so strictly
for hookup culture I know I
got that way but I think
I think everything really everything
gets taken to an absolute extreme to
where it can't even be bloody enjoyed I
mean look at in lockdown look how quick
people were to turn into absolute idiots
but it's I think that's happened with
that it's just too easy the reason why I
say that is because I read from the
guardian right because the guardian says
um data from outside sources suggests
that most people on dating apps are not
finding lost in relationships or
marriages through these platforms
I think they had good intentions that
they they probably started off with you
know what we're gonna we're gonna add to
this growing digital age and connect
people in ways that have never been
connected before because what it should
do is facilitate conversation and and
actually boost communication but what it
actually does in in connecting people
you're actually separating people at the
same time so what's what's come from
that is that
as humans we are opportunists in
whatever we can do for the men we found
a way to have a massive access to a
massive pool of women that would never
would have had access to before so like
if you back in the day before dating
apps if you lived in East London
the maximum women that you're going to
get around is the women in your area now
whether you live in east south
Hertfordshire Liverpool these women are
now all accessible too so so so now it's
it's just it's open the floodgates for
people to just move frivolously it's too
much Choice isn't it that's the thing
that's why no one's picking or or
staying because it's just too much for
the women or for the men
um well I suppose both if you're going
on here
too what do you mean you think it's for
the men well they're not but they have
too much Choice as well yeah I think
anything online but I'm saying that it
all depends on the app I see uh 50 I see
something on line about Tinder it was
only 15 was women I think that's wild I
think it's a small percentage of men
that don't want to settle down I think
most men want a wife and kids yeah and
most men are pretty realistic with what
they can get I don't find that the more
variety men like I don't find that most
men have that much choice
yeah men women have more Choice than men
as you can as you can probably tell like
as I've always said ladies if you were
to walk out this house right now looking
your quote-unquote bummiest you'd still
get attention from me
but do you just think that's because
edius is a biological driver do you just
think that's because men seeks so
regardless of or do you think there's
something more to that go on Eddie
you've gone after that see I think men
seeks it but at the same time there's a
lot of men who are very realistic in
what it is they're able to attain so
they'll be more than happy to have one
woman he would like
take it K2 and could cater to them and
and they'd be at the game but the
reality is that most men and even from a
historical standpoint didn't get
opportunity to reproduce so in the
context of a dating app like it
definitely probably favors women more
men would probably want to get more out
of it but they can't we've seen the
stats you know women are swiping 14
whilst men are swiping 67. so if
anything men probably want relationships
more than women do on those apps but
they're not being but are they being
clear about that
maybe like maybe that's what they feel
like but you've seen the male side so
what what do you see
[ __ ]
I've only twice used these sites and
then it's been a one day you should
download it as as a woman and see what
you get don't don't stop that fishing
what do you mean like Rita like research
purposes and just see their [ __ ]
messages you get bombarded with some of
them are that's the other thing I think
what about Max horrible matchmaking I
think that there's dating apps and then
there's matchmaking sites so I know
someone who's trying to develop an app
where it's more matchmaking based so
e-harmony yeah but then there's an
actual human who tries to match you to
people who have a similar so it may
start with an online platform but then
there's a human element to it where it's
like right do they have the same values
as you right do you you know when you
talk about what era do they live in are
you going to be able to sustain a
relationship when you're living like on
the opposite side of the world and then
they actually provide you with profiles
or people they think might match with
that's a good idea that's more whereas I
started on the Internet or online
there's actually an element of like back
and forth where it isn't just you're
swiping saying that do you think like
long distance relationships when it
comes to apps are sustainable no hell no
happened to pen power waste of time
literally just sending needs back and
forth for that face pound says I think
if you meet someone say if you met
someone on holiday it's a different
situation isn't it you spend like two
weeks together or whatnot that's a bit
different like long term but to start
something long term or you're not even
there it seems a bit much I think just
get rid of dating let's be honest we
need to teach humans what it means to
interact with each other once again it's
money now though most of them are paid
and that's true but I think we have to
look at the root cause of a lot of these
issues and and I'm always going to go
back to this but I think the spark and
the growth in in single parent mothers
and raising Sons not to be goal getters
and have the ability to go and Court a
woman on the street is just creating so
much negativity in how we interact with
each other because of like like I was
taught literally you go out there and
you learn the hard way right I I would I
had to grow if there was a numbers game
me and my boy would pick a location
we're not leaving until at least 10
numbers right and through that you learn
how to communicate with people you learn
what works and what doesn't you don't
want people can interact with and what
people find weird or whatever
rejection and how to face rejection yeah
I think people would be entitled now
like that's actually the important
people get offended if you're not
interested and you're trying to say in a
nice way and it's like oh well you're
this anyway it's like then it's instant
like defense mechanism whereas people
used to be able to face rejection when
you could just talk to people but I
think that's right now Everyone's
entitled people can say whatever they
want online and there's no repercussions
but then instant gratification is part
of the internet yeah because you know
um men I've always said that the
internet has given men access to women
that they would never ever gain access
to tracks in their whole life in general
life like you can go on Instagram find
this woman twerking find this woman who
looks like this and you can interact
with them to some degree and that woman
would never ever give you the time of
day in real life right and so what it is
is that on both the male side and the
female side
um
these apps are giving people a false
sense of reality right and so what
happens is when we enter women a false
sense of reality I I agree with you pal
right I actually agree with you I asking
the average man his experience on dating
apps he's yeah reality hits him quit a
small percentage and that small
percentage of men can still kill it in
real life no that that's very true but
I'm just saying when when it comes time
to interact with people
um on the real level like you know in in
person I think you know it
people have people take that psychology
from the app and try to juxtapose it in
real life and it doesn't work it doesn't
work so for me
if it doesn't work then why are most
people meeting online now it just
devil's advocate here is this easier
it's literally just the most simplistic
means to an end because for me I I say
this like I'm still far more successful
with women person in person like
um in real interactions and I am on
dating apps like dating apps is just is
a case of covering different bases it's
like different different standards and
like you're because you know YouTube the
numbers game so 40 that guys are swiping
40 of the time because it's a numbers
game so that 14 of females there's bound
to be one that's right yeah so you're
getting volume you know you know what's
interesting about dating apps is we get
more data and more information about
what people want as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demanding Ties on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible